let's go to Comedy Central and we'll
pitch them a sketch show because so much
of what made the pedome show popular was
the sketches so we're like will be the
pop culture sketch show their key and
peel was on at the time but there was
nobody doing just like we do in Indiana
Jones or Friday the 13th we love that
stuff Star Wars we love that stuff so
we'll be the pop culture sketch show
Kent alterman who was the was the Love
Ken was the head of conference at the
time uh we're in a meeting just like
this just like the three of us except
orange here and uh in the small talk
that sort of Swedish 10 minutes where
you just kind of shoot the [ __ ] because
nobody just wants to start like here's
the idea imagine Luke Skywalker but he
works out of Supercuts like it's nobody
wants to start like that you start with
how are you right
in that 10 minutes we're about to pitch
a sketch show Kent Alderman says just
offhandedly as a joke he goes well one
thing's for sure we don't want another
[ __ ] sketch show and everyone laughs
and I'm like
[Music]
that's what I'm gonna pitch you
not anymore if there was a shredder if
there was a barrel fire in the room I
would have tossed the deck really so you
just aborted we mid meeting
just said we just wanted to check in and
see what you guys are up to and like
just didn't pitch it
he probably was like I thought it was a
pitch meeting we didn't pitch it we left
here's the best part though so this is
kind of a no and pirate knife right Rope
Rope burning
PD
goes in the car third person
just talking to me in the dick right now
Ryan just like a like a real
uh right in the ding
but I'm I'm real desperate and I'm real
it's not even for like
you know like it wasn't like how am I
gonna eat it was more like what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do like like an existential
like what is my life gonna be and I and
I said
it's one of those great little moments
um where you go okay
if you could do anything anything what
could you do and I don't want to be too
woo-woo but I think I I'm not even a
believer necessarily in like the hard
secret or manifesting or anything but I
am a big big Capital case uppercase
believer and if you can't see it no one
else is going to see it first you have
to see it right you want to be Harrison
Ford you have to go like I want to be
Harrison Ford I'm not saying that's
going to make it happen but if you can't
see yourself on manifest
sort of right green lighted you green
light at first because if you don't I
think you're going to unconsciously be
sabotaging yourself or limiting yourself
right you have to 100 believe in what
you're saying
at least take a second to ask yourself
if you can't see yourself on the Raiders
poster why and maybe clean that up
um maybe mommy loved you too much maybe
she loved you not enough but something
went funky fix that yeah so in the car I
I had enough self-love to go like let's
be real what would you do if you could
do anything and I think that's a really
important question it's that high school
guidance counselor question and I said
I'm obsessed with Chad Apatow my whole
life like for real I know everybody
loves Chad but like 40 year old virgin
meant a lot to me Knocked Up meant even
more to me I started getting divorced
when This is 40 was out if you recall uh
Paul Rudd's character in that movie is
named Peter and Leslie Mann tearfully is
like wondering if she's gonna stay with
Peter and I'm like I'm sitting next to
my wife who is cheating on me and I'm
like